president bailen's administration
says this second part of his
infrastructure plan called the
american families plan would invest nearly
$2 trillion in sectors like
health care and education the
administration says are investments
in human infrastructure
especially our children  for the
first time we are seeing a president
who says he wants to invest in our
children who have not entered school
with preschool education the secretary
of health and human services javier
becerra says that in addition to two years of
free preschool education the
administration of bailén also  wants to
offer two years of free university
including undocumented students
who have
deferred action known as daca
bailén also proposes to expand
government investments in the
health care sector to know that they can
still pay what that health insurance costs
the president wants to create a
public option  public health insurance, that is, a
plan offered by the government that would
create competition and
lower health insurance prices, but
the administration of president bailén
will have to fight for this plan to
become a reality since the
republican legislators say it is
too much  expensive and that would also increase
the national debt too much reporting
in washington
alexandra limon